foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to give my thoughts on all
of the new recent updates regarding
HBO's new Game of Thrones sequel series
based on The Life and Adventures of Jon
Snow now if this information is accurate
it will light The Game of Thrones fandom
on fire the only issue is as of right
now I'm not so sure that it's real for
those of you who don't know there are
many different Facebook accounts stating
HBO has finally confirmed they are
making a Jon Snow series with A Song of
Ice and Fire Author George R Martin as
well as Game of Thrones actor Kit
Harington not only that but they're also
saying HBO has officially announced they
will begin filming the Jon Snow sequel
Series in December now let me be the
first one to say I don't know where the
hell they are getting this new
information as of right now this
Facebook update has well over 100 000
likes so I'm not just making this up
myself even the photo they shared along
with the message does look like
something HBO would make but my guess is
some fan made that them themselves I
even saw another Facebook update that
had well over 30 000 likes so this
information has already been spreading
like wildfire all over social media now
when I saw this I did what I normally do
and I went looking for the sources
myself I searched all over the internet
in every social media service looking
for some sort of confirmation from
either HBO George RR Martin's not a Blog
website or any reliable website who's
known for breaking this sort of news as
of right now I haven't found any new
information that backs up what these
Facebook accounts are saying so I wanted
to make this video in an effort to get
to the bottom of it now we do know HBO
is working on a Jon Snow series with
Game of Thrones actor Mr Harrington this
was finally revealed a few months ago
when James Hibbert released his article
it was further confirmed by Amelia
better known as Daenerys who revealed
even more information during an
interview Amelia had said that she found
out from the man himself and that was
what led to George RR Martin confirming
it once again on his not a block website
he said they have been working on this
Jon Snow show since they began
developing all the other Game of Thrones
successor shows like House of the Dragon
not only did kit Harrington bring this
idea to HBO himself but he also brought
his own writers and directors so we do
know for a fact that the show is real
and HBO has been developing it I just
don't know where these Facebook accounts
got their new information I think this
might be a fabrication since I'm not
able to find HBO's confirmation anywhere
else now with that being said the other
reason why I decided to make the video
is because of the outside chance that it
might be real I don't want to be caught
sleeping at the wheel when something
this big might be happening behind the
scenes at the end of the day you never
really know how this information will
get revealed for all we know these
random Facebook accounts might have some
inside sources that we don't know about
not only that but if you watch all my
videos then you know I always say I will
let you know whenever there is any new
information regarding Game of Thrones or
House of the Dragon now that this
information is spreading all over the
Internet like wildfire I felt I had to
at least let you know even if it doesn't
end up being false which unfortunately I
ultimately believe it is I will keep
looking for reliable sources to confirm
the new information but as of right now
I would take it with a grain of salt at
least now you will know what's really
happening if you do see something like
this being shared on Facebook Instagram
or any other social media site like I've
said in other videos I think HBO will
want a green light other new shows now
that house of the Dragon has found such
massive success we know HBO is
developing at least five other shows so
they'll definitely want to get those off
the ground and moving forward now that
the Game of Thrones fandom is alive and
thriving again so leave me some of your
thoughts down below I'm always
interested in hearing what you have to
say as always I want to thank all of you
for watching another video I hope all of
you have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
foreign